also breaking tonight President Trump is
nominating Republican Congressman John
Radcliffe to be his Director of National
Intelligence in permanent form the
president tweeting a short time ago that
he would have completed the process
earlier but Radcliffe wanted to wait
until after an Inspector General report
was finished he calls Radcliffe an
outstanding man of great talent
let's bring in chief White House
correspondent John Roberts on the North
Lawn John's second time the charm for
congressman Radcliffe we will see well
usually they say third time's the charm
of this is the second kick at the can
for Texas congressman John Ratcliffe the
president announced his intention to
nominate Ratcliffe for DNI late last
July but after accusations of resume
padding cropped up the president allowed
Ratcliffe to withdraw saying that he was
likely in for a rough ride when it came
to Senate confirmation here's what
direct cliff told Fox Business is Maria
Bartiromo back then I made the decision
to withdraw from consideration because
you know if your political future comes
down to the vote of a hundred US
senators and you start out day one down
47 to nothing because every Democrat is
against you my concern was there's not a
lot of margin for error there so what
changed between last August and now as
you pointed out the president tweeted
that the IG report is out Ratcliffe
wanted to wait for that fox news's also
told that the Senate Majority Leader
Mitch McConnell and Richard Burr the
chairman of the Senate Intelligence
Committee are fully on board for what
they say will be a swift confirmation
process